it's not a gamble to say that Avengers
endgame is gonna be a massive success
because the anticipation for this film
is so big that get this after some movie
websites crashed following high demand
presale tickets started popping up on
eBay for up to $25,000 what meanwhile
the Avengers assembled to become some
real-life heroes at Disney's California
Adventure today at our nischelle Turner
was there
[Applause]
while the Avengers gathered outside some
unsuspecting kids from the Boys and
Girls Club were quietly playing nearby
in the Lego house when suddenly in came
our heroes to hand out of interest toys
when they look at you and you're a bit
of a hero off screen that's got to make
you feel really great it does absolutely
and sometimes you have to explain
they're like who use like Thor they're
like where's the hammer and the long
hair and the outfit being able to
provide any opportunity for kids to do
exactly what they do best just be a kid
and awesome
these Avengers are parents in real life
Paul Rudd has two kids Chris three
scarlet and Jeremy one each it's
encouraged me to do more for kids didn't
know I'm an actor
she just knows I'm Hawkeye and then I'm
on our pajamas do your kids have Thor
pajamas
hey John my kids are kind of one of them
thinks it's cool you know then I'm kind
of hanging on to that he's he's my
favorite you know the giveaway was part
of a four million dollar gift of toys to
children's hospitals around the country
announced today by Disney chairman
Robert Iger
you know the reason I think most of us
do it is is is that that you know that
looks on their faces
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]